now because it has only phenomenal
knowledge for its object this exposition
seems not to be science free and self
moving in its own peculiar shape yet
from this standpoint it can be regarded
as the path of natural consciousness
which presses forward to true knowledge
or is the way of the soul which journeys
through the series of its own
configurations as though they were the
stations appointed for it by its own
nature so that it may purify itself for
the life of the Spirit and achieve
finally through a completed experience
of itself the awareness of what it
really is in itself
Hinkel begins this short section number
77 in asking a question that's in some
degree rhetorical is this exposition
this Darsh telling this account that
he's providing here in the phenomenology
is this really science or is it
something else instead
is it really scientific might might be
the question they ask does it really
have the character the essence of the
kind of inquiry that is science and when
we look at the two issues that he brings
up we see that we're again we're dealing
with with Hegelian division shot a
Galilean science with something that's a
bit broader more comprehensive more self
reflective than what we ordinarily think
of as science today he talks about it
having to be free and self moving and I
think that you know we can relate to
that to some degree in talking about say
the need for science to be an autonomous
investigation but self moving means it
really sets its own agenda but it does
so in relation to what it's finding what
it's discovering it says I want to know
more about that I'm going to go and do
the work for that he also talks about it
as being concerned with only phenomenal
knowledge now this is kind of an
interesting point to think about for a
moment because if you look at a lot of
the philosophy of science in the 20th
century and even in the 19th century
they would say that all science can
really focus on is in fact phenomenal
knowledge the science cannot get behind
the appearances it can only work with
what can actually be observed and you
know we can extend our possibilities for
observation through all sorts of
apparatus and thought experiments and
deductions and you know all sorts of
things along those lines but ultimately
we're saying that if it is scientific it
has to be something that that falls
within the realm of the phenomenal Hegel
is saying I'm doing phenomenology here
as well I'm actually doing a
phenomenology not only of the sciences
with a you know sort of small s but of
the you know whole history of you
justice and the capacity to reflect upon
it at this time in the privileged
present but all of that is ultimately
going to be for Hegel still phenomenal
and there's going to be this interplay
that we're going to see in the next few
sections about you know what actually is
phenomenal
is there something beyond what we think
of as what we're we're getting here the
appearance so he goes on and he says
look what's really happening here is
that we're talking about a process
that's why I've got this arrow here
we're looking at a process that can be
understood in several different ways one
of them is to focus on what he's calling
natural consciousness and using the word
consciousness booboo sign there that
he's going to be using throughout the
the entire phenomenology what does it
mean for it to be natural consciousness
it means that it's sort of taken for
granted standpoint of a particular time
we've talked about this a little bit
before in previous sections but it's
good to sort of stress this natural
consciousness is the kind of standpoint
that one has and one's getting it from
one's culture from where one stands
without having to think about things
without having to to investigate it just
sort of comes to one and we're always in
some position where we have some sort of
natural consciousness even if it's to be
like total skeptics that can be part of
a culture that could be something that
somebody inherits and so there's always
things that a consciousness a particular
consciousness is taking for granted and
that's that's the natural consciousness
interestingly enough again be from
culture right and we offer opposed
nature and culture that's a whole
different conversation he also talks in
terms of the soul and here Hegel is
invoking a kind of common disjunction
between soul and spirit that's been
popular at various times in history
including his own era where this is
something that actually turns on a
distinction that Paul perhaps made men
to make perhaps did
to make as Paul engages a lot of really
fancy you know shifting rhetoric in his
letters Paul talks it at some points
about soul and at some points about
spirit now the Gnostics looked at that
and actually some some Orthodox
Christian fathers and doctors as well
looked at that is an important
distinction to make Hegel is going to
kind of pick up on that I don't want to
go too much into that other than to say
that soul would be something like
natural consciousness it's it's bound to
a particularity wherein a spirit has a
kind of universality to it so you know
where is where is natural consciousness
striving towards knowledge what is the
soul trying to you know go through these
stages to ultimately reach the life of
the Spirit and what's important here hey
giggles giggles talking in terms of just
Alton or stages steps shapes of
consciousness the translation here is
actually configurations so you're not
getting the fact that he's talking about
Gestalt in here but he's talking about
traversing this this path towards true
knowledge going through the series of
its own configurations as though they
were stations appointed it to it by its
own nature so the things that we're
going to be looking at as we're going
through the rest of the phenomenology
those are the stages those are the steps
the gestalt --an and Hegel thinks that
we need to pass through them one by one
by one and thereby sort of replicate
what's been going on through the
development of consciousness in history
now what is the payoff for them that's
what I've got over here notice the the
terms that he's using a completed
experience an awareness of and it's not
just the reason I put the dot dot dot
ellipsis there it's not just of say the
phenomena it's not just say of you know
things outside that we want to get to
know it's also of the self it's also
where we are where we as the knowing
subject we as those who participate in
the life of the Spirit it's it's
self-knowledge related to other
knowledge
knowledge about the other whether that
be another person whether that be the
past whether that be the natural world
whether that be a cultural world that we
feel alienated from all that is is is
involved in this sort of integrating
process so that's what's what's going on
in this section
natural consciousness will show itself
to be only the notion of knowledge or in
other words not to be real knowledge but
since it directly takes itself to be
real knowledge this path is a negative
significance for it and what is in fact
the realization of the notion counts for
it rather is the loss of its own self
for it does lose its truth on this path
the road can therefore be regarded as
the pathway of doubt or more precisely
as the way of despair for what happens
on it is not what is ordinarily
understood when the word doubt is used
shilly-shallying about this or that
presumed truth followed by a return to
that truth again after the doubt has
been appropriately to spell so that at
the end of the process the matter is
taken to be what it was in the first
place
on the contrary this path is the
conscious insight into the untruth of
phenomenal knowledge for which the
supreme reality is what is in truth only
the unrealized notion therefore the
thoroughgoing skepticism is also not the
skepticism with which an earnest zeal
for truth and science fancies that is
prepared and equipped itself in their
service the resolve in science not to
give oneself over to the thoughts of
others upon mere Authority but to
examine everything for oneself and
follow one only one's own conviction or
better still to produce everything
oneself and accept only one's deed as
what is true the series of
configurations which consciousness goes
through along this road is in reality
that detailed history of the education
of consciousness itself to the
standpoint of science that zealous
resolve results this education
simplistically is something directly
over and done with in the making of the
resolution but the way of the soul is
the actual fulfillment of the resolution
in contrast to the untruth of that view
now following one's own conviction is of
course more than giving oneself over to
Authority but changing an opinion
accepted on Authority into an opinion
held out of personal conviction does not
necessarily alter the content
the opinion or replace error with truth
the only difference being between being
caught up in a system of opinions and
prejudices based on personal conviction
and being caught up in one based on the
authority of others lies in the added
conceit that it is innate in the former
proposition the skepticism that is
directed against the whole range of
phenomenal consciousness on the other
hand renders the spirit for the first
time competent to examine what truth is
for it brings about a state of despair
about all the so-called natural ideas
thoughts and opinions regardless of
whether they are called one's own or
someone else's ideas with which the
consciousness that sets about the
examination of truth straight away is
still filled and hampered so that it is
in fact incapable of carrying out what
it wants to undertake
in section 78 Hegel is doing some very
interesting almost amazingly clear stuff
regarding the project that he's involved
in and that we as readers are embarking
on and one of the things that I don't
have on the board that we do want to
keep in mind is what he's talking about
here is what is going on when we're
going through these stages of
consciousness when we're traversing the
path that he has laid out he's going to
speak here about a road or a path of
despair or of doubt and that's a really
interesting location we'll come back to
that in a moment but what we want to
think about is that this path is
actually the pathway tracing out the
development of human consciousness he
actually speaks about it as the
education of human consciousness and an
education is different than merely
enough showing up and getting some
training consciousness is being
developed as being unfolded as having
its capacities revealed to it and worked
on the way something new is happening at
each stage and that something new is
being assimilated into later stages if
it ends up getting forgotten and left
behind then we have a bit of a problem
that does happen in history quite a bit
in the dialectical process doesn't
always produce successes now how do we
end up on this road of doubt or despair
beautiful.you no idea there then we have
to traverse this process without sort of
thinking ahead of time that well it's
all going to turn out you know well in
the end human history has been inhabited
by a couple different motifs one of them
is when we get to that spot over there
it's going to all make sense because
we've got sort of the blueprint for it
and that's where the real stuff is going
to happen that's the optimistic
viewpoint in history it's all crap and
it's just the same crap over and over
and over again through different
permeate
that that's another viewpoint that's a
rather pessimistic viewpoint on human
history Hegel is he advocating something
that is somewhat like the optimistic
view but he's saying that we have to go
through this this process as if we don't
know that it couldn't be the other way
this is where it gets really really
interesting to reflect on just what is
going on in Hegel is he truly the
optimist the real is the rational the
rationals of real everything's already
completed in the system that's one view
of Hegel or is he saying maybe the
future is still somewhat open and I'm
giving you the tools here so I leave
that up to you to sort of think about
now he starts off talking about natural
consciousness again which we have
covered in the last section and he says
that natural consciousness and its
relationship to knowledge is less
straightforward than it assumes one of
the features of natural consciousness of
the sort of body of knowledge the body
of what passes as being a well-informed
person having the right formation having
the right ideas about things is that it
takes itself as having knowledge but you
know you go back to classic you know
text classic dialogues like for example
Plato's dialogues with Socrates and he
starts asking people about their their
natural consciousness with respect to
things like virtue or what knowledge is
and they start hemming and hawing they
start saying well I thought it like me
know for example
man I'm giving speeches about this
what's going on here I I thought I knew
what I was talking about obviously other
people thought I knew what I was talking
about but when it's really put to the
dialectical task it turns out that all
the actual consciousness has is the
notion of knowledge and that there's
sort of a bar here to knowledge itself
to what it is that it needs to yeah so
it's destabilized its its relativized
you can say in the process now why is he
using this term
notion or be Grif here he plays quite
often in a lot of these passages but
can't double game with this because we
have an ocean of knowledge and that's
better than just sort of a blank idea
because there is some sort of
developmental process going on there
remember when when you have the Hegelian
notion there is some sort of you know
self authoring and reincorporation of
that other Ness and that is going out of
natural consciousness but it's not it's
not fully developed it's not going
through all the way there is a completed
notion Hegel says of knowledge that
natural consciousness is actually aiming
for that it's it's haunted by and the
difference between these two is part of
what is haunting it so natural caution
consciousness is gonna try to push
through that and in the process of doing
so it gets revealed to not be as
knowledgeable as a thought it was so
that introduces doubt and that can
introduce despair now Hegel has some
really interesting things to say about
doubt at this point he says when we're
talking about doubt we're not talking
about the ordinary sense that people
have like well you know what am I gonna
have for dinner you know I don't know is
there something in the crock pot waiting
for me when I get home I'm kind of in
doubt about that but then I get home and
turns out I did turn the crock pot on
and put you know some sort of thrown
together dish in there or you know
there's nothing there and now I know and
he calls this shilly-shallying dick you
know when I say screwing around
puttering with the things that we want
to know about and that's not really
doubting that's just sort of playing
around so he says there's a return to
that truth again after the doubt has
been appropriate appropriately dispelled
so that at the end of the process the
matter is taken to be what it was in the
first place
that's not a productive that's not a
changing
kind of doubt now think about a
different kind of doubting I doubt
whether my wife is really faithful to me
now I could have the you know I get the
private investigator and he or she goes
out and follows him around you know for
for a month or so nothing's happening
and I say alright everything's back to
normal hunky-dory or they bring me some
photographs and nowadays I supposed to
be JPEGs right and that the email to you
and they say I've got some bad news for
you mr. Stambler and now you know my
situation has changed but now I have
some some consume knowledge that's not
quite what he giggles talking about now
imagine if you were wondering about that
sort of thing and you're doubting
whether somebody is really sincere or
faithful in their commitments and that's
beginning to change you could change you
in bad ways right you could become turn
into a paranoid suspicious jerk the kind
of person who actually drives somebody
else into somebody else's arms there's
great movies about that sort of thing
especially like the French movie he'll
fare exactly that sort of thing happens
in it now that's a different sort of
process of doubting there there's
something dialectically productive so
Hegel says on the contrary that this
path is the conscious insight into the
untruth of phenomenal knowledge untruth
of their being everything wrapped up
within the realm of what seen what's
what's granted what not natural
consciousness is up to he says for which
the supreme reality is what is the truth
only the unrealized notion over here
it's the completed notion right so this
this skepticism is not the skepticism
with which an earnest zeal for truth and
science and fancies is prepared and
equipped itself for the service now he's
introducing skepticism and skepticism is
doubt only turned into a general
attitude should turn into even a method
and and science modern science was often
quite skeptical about certain things
- skeptical because of course you can't
actually do anything if you're hyper
skeptical but we want to get to this
completed notion of knowledge and we
realized that what we've got so far
phenomenal knowledge is incomplete an
hour
we're like oh man what am I gonna do
maybe none of this is any good maybe I
can't get beyond maybe I should in fact
fall into a kind of skepticism and Hegel
goes on and he says this thoroughgoing
skepticism is not the skepticism which
is earnest deal for truth and science is
doing all right so there's two different
kinds of skepticism here the resolve in
science not to give oneself over to the
thoughts of others here we have this
this this issue down here on mere
authority but to examine everything for
oneself and follow only one's own
convictions or kind of still to produce
everything oneself you know the ultimate
DIY right and accept only ones deed as
what is true so what happens with
natural consciousness natural
consciousness where did it get its ideas
from about what counts as knowledge you
know what it can take for true what it
can use to make some progress so I got
it from somebody else generally from
some sort of authority a body of
authority doesn't matter who it is it's
somebody other than the self and so the
person says like Descartes did or
actually like Hobbes did in in large
respect and in you know his own project
empiricism and is in large respect a way
of saying I'm going to find things out
for myself I'm not just going to listen
to the experience of others I am the
experiencing self who's going to find
this out so empiricism and rationalism
really actually reinforce each other in
lot in philosophy in any case what
happens is the self says if I want to
get over here I can't just rely on what
other people have been saying whether
they've been teaching me
because all that's going to give me as
this notion of knowledge not the real
thing when he happens in the process
through history like Hegel says is that
this happens over and over and over
again in important ways that contribute
something new where a particular self
following out its own convictions
rejecting the the to some degree what
other people are putting forth in front
of it and exercising a certain kind of
freedom towards that produces something
that hasn't been you know brought up
before now that can become of course a
new Authority and that is in fact what
what happens throughout the course of
history so he says the series of
configurations the gestalt ax which
consciousness goes through along this
road is in reality the detailed history
of the education of consciousness itself
to the standpoint of science so we've
got this building process going on
throughout all of human history a lot of
divergences he's not saying that
everything is constantly progress or
anything like that but on the whole in
human history in development we have
something going on that is introducing
more and more to the very consciousness
of humanity itself so he goes on and he
says the zealous resolve represents this
education simplistically as something
directly over and done with in the
making of the resolution we know with
just about anything simply saying I'm
going to do this doesn't mean that it
actually happens but the way of the soul
is the actual fulfillment of the
resolution in contrast to the untruth of
that view so this is something that one
actually has to learn you might say
experientially but the experience that
we're talking about is not you know
showing up someplace and taking a
seminar instead or you know putting your
hands in something oh now I know what
goop feels like rather it's thinking
it's reflecting along it's going through
the entire process that's detail
in the phenomenology so he says let's
think this out now we've got this
contrast between following one's own
convictions versus giving over to
Authority and that means giving over to
the authority of somebody else somebody
else's convictions because they work at
one time you know in that same position
of the self
so he says following one's own
conviction is more than giving oneself
over to Authority so there's kind of an
advance in doing that it's important it
for any sort of human development that a
person may actually break to some degree
with the past break to some degree with
with the minds of others and say I use
the we'll use the first person singular
but what's the problem with that heimo
goes out and he says the only difference
between being caught up in a system of
opinions and prejudices based on
personal conviction because that's very
possible
following your own personal conviction
might in fact turn out to be just
following you know your own ideas about
things you know if you reject natural
consciousness that's not to say that
your own idea of things is any better as
a matter of fact it could be worse maybe
you're actually benefiting by taking on
the perspective of other people who
manage to make it through their lives
instead of reinventing everything and
this is the constant problem that
adolescents face isn't it they need to
break away to some degree but if you
break away quite often you find out that
what you're engaging in is adolescent
nonsense and then you regret it later on
so opinions and prejudices they don't
make it it doesn't make any difference
whether you're getting them from
yourself or whether you're getting them
from somebody else he says that there's
an added conceit that comes with getting
them from yourself that is innate in the
former position now he says he goes on
here and he goes back to this issue of
skepticism the skepticism that's
directed against the whole range of
phenomenal consciousness the whole range
of everything is being perceived not
only perceived but felt imagine
intuited all this sort of stuff
developing throughout history that's all
phenomenal reality for for or that's all
phenomenal consciousness for Hegel he
says renders the spirit for the first
time competent to examine what truth is
this despair this skepticism is is a
necessary step that we do need to pass
through in order to make some progress
so I don't have to say I'm going to do
you know I'm gonna be my own man I'm
gonna be my own woman I'm gonna you know
be original or anything like that that's
fine that's kind of superficial that's
not real skepticism the real skepticism
faces up to the possibility that perhaps
this is all nonsense perhaps none of
this works perhaps it's all bad and then
it recovers from that he says it brings
about a state of despair about all so
called natural ideas thoughts and
opinions regardless of whether they're
someone else's or one's own ideas with
which the consciousness that sets about
the examination of truth straightaways
is still filled and hampered so that
it's incapable of doing what needs to do
so what we need to do is pass through
the kind of purification where we not
only say well I'm gonna like reject
Authority I'm gonna get away from you
know my upbringing I'm going to get away
from my prevailing culture I'm going to
be different I'll be like you know an
Apple user and you know one of those
original thinkers Hegel says that's not
going far enough you need to also feel
the spear about whether you can even get
it right yourself and you know when I
think about somebody who actually did
this you know who comes to mind for me
is Rene Descartes and then another guy
comes to mind that way for me as well
it'd be Blaise Pascal two guys from the
same time who really didn't exemplify
what Hegel is talking about their
further back of the dialectic of course
for as far as Hegel is concerned because
there are early moderns but they are
embodying that sort of I got a really
through doubt and skepticism mindset
that Hegel's talking about is being
necessary for tracing out the path of
the development of spirit